Film Courage: Why don't we introduce ourselves? Brian Avenet-Bradley:  I'm Brian Avenet-Bradley.
I make horror films with my wife
Lawrence is overseas shooting or she
would love to be here but basically
we've done five horror films together
it's the genre we like and we just
finished our last film Echoes of Fear
which has had its world premiere like
weekend a few days ago at Shriek Fest on
played to festival sense so it's been
doing really good
good audience response three best
feature horror Awards which were really
happy of one of them was voted on by the
audience which makes it even more
special because that's what we're trying
to do is get it out there and get the
audience feedback from it
congratulations Orson Oblowitz: Hi, my name is Orson Oblowitz. I'm a director I my first film
just actually came out today
Oh congratulations okay it's called the
Queen of Hollywood Boulevard and then a
film that I finished afterwards just
premiered last month of Fright Fest
house where the home is I also love
horror films and but Queen is kind of a
crime film as well hard noir you know
and uh yeah so I make movies and
convince people to let me make things as
long as I can
very nice congratulations my name is
Christopher Ray I've been producing
directing films for the last eight nine
years I've done 70 films of the producer
20 as a director have done horror action
life time family you name it just
finished directing a women's thriller
and I had a horror film last year called Circus Kane come out I had one this year
called minutes to midnight that just
came out I have a comedy coming up and
oh and Johnny gruesome came out today
with someone producer with gentlemen
back in Buffalo cool congratulations
I'm Andrew P Jones I'm a director writer
producer editor but in the business for
33 years started in special-effects
morphed into producing directing and
post my first feature film I released in
2010 called kings of the evening which
was a history
a period drama my next film was haunting
of cellblock 11 or and then this year
released a film called darkness reigns
which was also horror today is October
16th it happens to be darkness reigns
day in Jefferson City Missouri where we
shot the film where the mayor actually
gave us our own day oh very cool one
year anniversary
Royce Gorsuch: I'm Royce Gorsuch and first-time filmmaker
and I did a film called mad genius it's
grounded sci-fi project shot here in LA
so our first question and I'm I'm sure
we'll find a rhythm to this in terms of
who wants to answer first you know maybe
we could just go one way and back the
other but first question is how old were
you when you made your first film what
did you make it on and what genre was it
well for me my first film was probably
when I was 10 years old with a VHS
camcorder and a few action figures it
was released in my living room nice
my parents watched it very nice first
film super 8 again as a kid 10 years old
or whatnot in the canyons of San Diego
with my brother recreating Star Wars or
a Western or World War 2 movie and
that's
my first film was when I was 13 and it
was like a skate video on high eight
that had some sort of very loose
narrative to it and it was all edited in
the high eight camera my first film was
when I was ten it was a horror film
called house of Frankenstein very
original title but even you're ten years
old so gifs got my friends together we
all play different parts it was shot by
my dad on the ODE VHS camera back when
they had the separate deck from the
camera he was an optical engineer at
Magnavox so he kind of like took it out
of the laboratory so that's how we did
it i played dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde and did
an in-camera transformation because we
also could not edit it at that time so
loads of fun you can see I'm the oldest
one because I'm the only when they shot
him on super 8 film there was a film
what was your first film where you
received a festival laurel for it and
was it worth it was it worth entering
the the festival and and did you get
good feedback I mean let's shake things
up a little bit let's yeah what was it
worth it entering and all the festival
fees without naming any names of course
well we'll bleep them out yeah why don't
we start doing a starter sorry to put
you in the hot seat we'll switch up I
think my first festival was my hometown
Salem Oregon the Salem Film Festival for
a student short that I did that was
really worth it for me
just because I was you know in high
school and they were playing legitimate
films at that festival so I got to be
there and experience it so that it was a
positive experience
great yeah okay
the real Hollywood story very good my
first movie Kings of the evening did
bang-up business with the festival's
open the number of them closed a number
of them won tons of awards all over the
country then I started realizing what a
business festivals is there they they
exist on our work it does it help I
don't personally think so unless you're
in some of the bigger festivals and
people have told me that you know unless
you're in Sundance or can or Telluride
or something it's not gonna do much for
you in fact I remember doing a panel
similar to this I'm not gonna say which
festival or which city I was in and the
question came up what is this award
gonna do for you for your film and
everyone gave their kind of canned
answers and got to me and I said to
honestly nothing that's the true honest
answer this this award will do nothing
it feels great feeds the ego it's
wonderful fills up shelf space but no it
will do nothing for the film and that's
the way I kind of feel about them
they're fun to do but I
enough thank you
House is now the home was International
Film Festival only one best film so that
was the first time I've entered and I
think I've done it one more time which
was for mercenaries didn't do anything
for me I was at the time I was already
in the business and working so actually
helping me did not help me in any way
so my first festival Laurel experience
was actually with my film now the queen
of Hollywood Boulevard it would have
premiered at the Boston underground Film
Festival funny enough we had action I
had somehow gotten distribution before
getting
festivals so I had already kind of like
oh yeah it already kind of like Gardner
around it the festival process for me
was a kind of arduous one where it was a
lot of like big festivals being like we
really want your film and then not
taking the movie so it was it was pretty
soul-crushing but um honestly what I
actually had a very good experience with
the film at the festival since it built
a community around the film and it's
built relationships and good press
around it and some bad breasts which you
can use this good press so yeah I think
in the end I would like a lot of my
money back from festival submissions
because I paid actors less than that but
it was very helpful in the end of the
day to build a community around the film
and help it with its release I guess but
the difference on this a little bit but
the first Laurel was our first film I
gave my life freezer that's fre easy '
er which is about this guy who killed
his wife and stuck her in the freezer
because you love her so much you
couldn't get rid of her and we were
actually invited to the Hamburg Film
Festival so I didn't cost any money
which international festivals is a
general role you don't have to pay to
submit because they're funded by
governments usually don't pay any money
to submit to those but it was a great
experience because the once again cuz
it's International Festival they flew me
out to Germany and they put me up at a
hotel I got to meet a bunch of people
who are all looking me like why are you
in this festival with your little tiny
movie but it was it was actually a
really good experience how much did help
that movie I don't know though the
festival that it probably helped us the
most was our third film darker Mane's we
got into the it was the fifth year of a
horror festival in town called shriek
fest and we won best horror feature and
that basically set up like a slew of
other festival screenings I think we did
like 23 more festivals and it did kind
of lead we did that per year
and it did lead to us getting our first
good distribution deal for one of our
movies so it can work I understand what
you guys are saying especially Andrew I
think the biggest caveat now is the
whole festival thing has completely
changed
most festivals do not program their
festival from submissions they dis a
sulli take your submission fee and this
is the way it is most I would say 85% of
the slots our basically producers reps
have placed a movie or their Studios who
already have distribution for their
movie and they're just using the
festival to promote the film they don't
need they are to have a release date
I mean quiet place great horror movie
why is it playing in South by Southwest
when it already has a distributor and a
release date
it's the 19 million dollar movie taking
a slot of some little indie that someone
killed themselves to do so the caveat to
I think submitting to festivals is don't
go crazy don't submit to too many talk
to filmmakers and they'll tell you which
ones actually will program their
festival based on the submissions
doesn't mean you'll get in but at least
it means you have a better shot of
getting in because 85% the slots aren't
already taken before they even open it
to submission so yeah one more thing
about laurel wreaths I was told by a
distributor and I don't know if you guys
have had any of the same experiences but
certain stores I was told actually don't
like the DVDs having a bunch of laurel
wreaths on them because it it makes it
seem like an art film and that's not
necessarily their audience their buyers
so you can get all the laurel wreaths
you want and it's and then in some cases
the distributor doesn't want to use them
when we'll take them off the DVD because
it's not good for business you know ii
and andrew because our darker Mane's
which got one best horror feature the
DVD distributor did not want to put best
horror feature from shriek fest on the
DVD because he said that they don't care
it's about festivals and I of course was
like but it's a horror festival it's not
an art festival but they still didn't
want to put it on so to andrew's point
that's really interesting because I
would imagine without mentioning the
name it's probably a large chain that
piece might doesn't get people health
insurance anyway so we'll skip over the
name of it but
so knowing that you could actually make
money from your film how did they want
you to market it even though I would
think an art film would be great those
are the kind of films I love but it
sounds like that's not what sells so
maybe you can touch on how did the
distributor want you to make it appear
less sort of indie more there is no
appearance they just want the film to
speak for itself they want the cast to
speak for itself they hope that the
faces on the cover are recognizable
enough and will bring in an audience so
that's pretty much how no they didn't
want to market it as anything other than
this one you know it was a
african-american period drama so yeah it
just was what it was interesting okay
anybody else have something to add about
okay I kind of talked about my first
festival experience my high school short
but I've of course with mad genius had
the festival experience with my first
feature and we premiered in Fright Fest
in London we played in Austin and then
San Francisco and had you know really
pretty good responses there and the
festivals we don't use the reads in our
or the laurels in our marketing the
sales agent does use the festivals when
he's selling to distributors as sort of
like a you know badge of honor but
publicly we don't necessarily market the
festival laurels
okay so there's sort of a time and a
place to make the laurels be known I get
add one more thing on festivals which I
found really interesting maybe for the
first time on this one because we played
three so far is what I've been using
them for is it's free audience market
testing to find out what people get
really jazzed about in the movie to help
us figure out the marketing because I
can tell from the QAS
what people really get excited about and
I also kind of flip the QA
to the audience so I've actually been
able to get a lot of mark free market
research from the festival audience that
if I was putting together you know a
market screening test of the movie would
cost me a lot of money so that's a
little side benefit that you can do to
add festivals which is not gonna help
you know yes sir the distribution but at
least gives you an idea of what you've
got because it's a filmmaker obviously
you can't see the forest for the trees
sometimes and you know movies are for
other people to enjoy and wat so it's
kind of important to know what their
reaction is a great point so you can
hear when they laugh or if something
just falls flat and you're like oh I
thought people would love that well yeah
and a scary horror movie you can tell
from audience reactions a lot what
scares what doesn't but also really from
the QA is great because you can really
from the questions people are asking you
can get a very good sense of what people
get really we're really interested in
and fascinated about in the movie and
and if something didn't work you'll find
that out too cuz you'll get a lot of
questions like I dunno
speaking of which does anyone have a
question in terms of turning it to the
audience for QA anybody have any
questions about festivals or okay
curious have you ever asked a festival
to wave festival fees and how was it
received I'm sensing there's a story
there right okay yeah I would I would
second the notion that a lot of festival
fees are not worth it
I would really focus you know on the
festivals that like do your research as
to which ones you think are going to
accept you and will benefit you and that
you want to be a part of and all the
other ones are not worth it I I
definitely have done a shotgun approach
in the past you know and found that that
wasn't really worth it and then what I
found also is that by getting into one
that's decent then you start to get
invited to others and when that takes
place then there is no fee and there's
you know you you just know you're in
that's so it's kind of about getting
like a the first good one
can really have a ripple effect you know
and I don't totally mean to knock
festivals I mean if it's a short film
and you're not going to rent a huge
theater and it's a great night for you
and your cast and crew to go out and you
know then have drinks afterwards or
whatever then it sounds like it's worth
it but as a rule to try to continually
launch a film that's that's kind of
where I was was going and and hoping to
hear from it it sounds like I think you
just know that if you're if you're gonna
do it have a targeted approach I mean I
know some people who are like I'm
submitting to 50 festivals I'm like what
are you doing
and so much money you could use some of
that money from marketing buy some
online ads or you know market better
marketing materials or whatever I mean
so I think yeah what you said like
Target it did you have something to say
yes so yeah I got to a point where I was
my film was being invited by a lot of
festivals and then I started noticing
that I was opening night or closing
night and then when the awards would
come up some film that I honestly really
thought was awful would win best of the
festival and and I and I would just walk
away to school I don't understand this
I'm why is my film and it was a well
your honors being the opening or closing
film and it's like I don't know what to
do with that I don't know what I can't I
can't write an essay on a poster
explaining that I can't you know I don't
know what to do so by the last one and
maybe a little bit of a jerk move but I
was invited to yet another one and I
said well I'll come if you give me an
award and they did okay they made up an
award special for me and made a
presentation and they did and look there
were some great festival experiences and
so I'm not gonna say they're all they
all use the film's great some are not so
great
some were a lot of fun some were not so
fun somewhere very kind and giving so
yeah I can't knock them because we had a
good time and it gave us a lot of stuff
to talk about a lot of PR speaking of PR
Orson you said something about you you
received a few negative reviews which
you actually don't think are bad
and I'm wondering have others received
that or have any of you had your films
let's say torrent it or something and it
actually helped Ivan we've heard of
cases where certain people's films being
you know ripped actually sometimes helps
sell the film that's fine I actually
have not looked on BitTorrent I'm sure
my film is on there because that's the
audience's kind of gamer culture and I
definitely found a link that surprised
me it was like free movie something
something and I went on there and and
it's like it had eight thousand views
and you could just like watch my movie
on this like legitimate looking website
and I was just like that's insane that's
just out there on like the first page of
Google so that was really pretty
shocking good shocking sorry or bad bad
okay well you know I mean just to think
that someone stealing like you're like
wow someone's stealing something I'm a
that's interesting yeah you know I I
almost did this thing that I was gonna
put on the front of my film like a
30-second selfie video of myself and
basically as soon as it would come on
before anything I'd say hey I'm Royce
and I created this film and I spent
three years of my life and I put myself
into like financial straits and like
lived on the set and like did all this
crazy shit and so I'd really appreciate
it if you didn't steal my movie because
and I didn't do that and I really
actually wish I would have because when
you watch my film you know I have a
pretty awesome distributor and they have
a cool logo and it comes up and you look
at it and people you know they just
think oh this is just some you know
million dollar movie you know but the
truth is that that's the exact opposite
and put people consumers they just they
don't know and they've sort of been
spoiled by Hollywood and you know I feel
like
the value of film with digital
distribution has obviously plummeted in
culture I think so those are my two
cents what about a bad review there
sometimes trolls help can perpetuate
something and actually help it - did
anything happen where yeah you know
reviews are interesting I had my film is
pretty divisive it's like people love it
or they don't get it it's like one or
the other and I found that interesting
because the whole purpose of my film for
me was to get people thinking and I kind
of count those as both sort of a win but
I didn't count on people being so
vicious in some cases especially on like
ratings like not necessarily press press
were all fine you know they they did
professional work if they didn't like it
they said why whatever but there's like
they're the trolls right the the
faceless internet goblin out there yeah
and I you know there was one guy he gave
me one star and just like berated me on
IMDB and I clicked on his profile and I
had seen that he had given a thousand
movies one-star including Christopher
Nolan's first movie which is I think
incredible and it was just like there's
like an army of these people out there
who who are doing this and they have no
idea what it takes to make something so
that was really challenging for me my
because this is my first film I've never
experienced anything like that before
so that was that was challenging and
definitely made me like humanity a
little less I would say it does also
feel really good to get those reviews
that totally get it and they they speak
to it and they saw the subtext and they
look through you know the surface and
really like got it and those feel really
good and of course those are the ones we
post on our marketing
yeah we hit a couple a number of
subjects there the trolls the the
negative trolls yes it's very
frustrating distributors usually always
say don't worry about it it's it's
meaningless they don't they don't care
the filmmakers we care because it hurts
cuz we put so much into it there's
nothing you can do about it as far as
like home video and people stealing your
stuff I actually have a friend who used
to work for a major studio in home video
and he would tell me they never went
after anybody they just it's just part
of the business those people that are
gonna dig in and download something and
pirate it they're gonna do that they're
not the person that's going to go and
pay to watch it that's just not what
they do
so his attitude always was it's just
part of the business it's part of the
circle of life for a film and don't
sweat it
and you're not losing anything people
are still watching it talking about it
that's what you want that was pretty
much everything yeah either somebody
gives you a good or bad review it means
they watch the film so in that aspect of
it I'm fine I've gotten completely tore
up or let me try they give me like half
a star there's one starting it should be
less I've had people email me asking for
their money back so they're yeah no it
was good I did did megashark versus
crocosaurus for sci-fi channel and a
viewer in Spain wrote me things say I
hurt his brain I need I need to give him
back his money
when it comes to you know so when it
comes to reviews it doesn't bother me
I've been around the business for so
long that the guy who wants to sit in
the basement never come to a movie set
and see what everyone's doing and
working hard and wants to complain fine
if the guy wants to come and work on a
set and meet everybody and they'll then
still complain then it's a different
different aspect to it when it comes to
the torrent part of it you in my mind
you're stealing from the filmmaker let
it be a dollar fifty cents you know
whatever we're entitled to for making
the film
by doing so you know I can give an
example for circus King which came out
last year we found a site that had 8.3
million views now mind you monetary
value dollar would have been something
we've taken down different sites and
they've mean it's uncountable so yeah
torrent sites are probably the vein to a
filmmakers existence worse than anything
to add I I kind of took your what you
said and I turned it into a question no
no I I mean I haven't dealt with torn
sites as this movie literally came out
today but I'm sure by the time I get
home we'll be on some good sites you
know yeah you know sod you know I have
my producer looking out just for fun but
what I was saying about the bad press
was I we just had a review come out by
an actual person who claims to be a sort
of film publication and he had he hated
it so much that he actually used amazing
colorful language to describe the film
he called my my 65 year old mother some
sort of a sideshow cheap Liberace of
Hollywood Wow and the poor man's
anjelica huston
Oh know that this is going in our next
little teaser we're making no I love
this stuff so then I I've actually now
been doing this thing where I'm like
because it's a film that stars a 65 year
old woman she's a total badass she's
like going around you know la it's just
it's a it's a wild film and you know
she's got a girlfriend and you know we
were doing what we do you know trying to
do something different and the comments
are terrible by the trolls but my whole
plan and then what we're doing is we're
just gonna turn it against them and say
you know bang bang bang look at all
these terrible things people are saying
go see this movie not as if it's a bad
movie it's actually an attack on the
main characters look and gender and who
she is so for me that only motivates I
think the audience that I want to see
the film or to go see it to support that
type of character and that type of
person and yeah so I kind of been
I mean I'm a little confrontational I
guess at times because I kind of been
fight a little my my my girl from the
other day told me that I was kicking the
hornet's nest a lot these days with it
like I'm trying to you know really get
the kind of ready a certain type of
ready troll community to really talk
some smack on the movie so I can kind of
use it these comments to for my benefit
and that's what I've been doing you know
these bad reviews come out I mean not if
they've honest things to say that are
bad about the film that's great like I'm
that's your prerogative that's how you
feel that's I respect that I'd stop for
everyone I don't make films for everyone
I don't think I think it's very hard for
anyone to make a phone for everyone but
I'm kind of taking the bad and trying to
turn it and the bad like we're talking
about like control bad like the you know
these real you know the basement
basement trolls and goblins and whatever
you know hobbits and yeah there's a
movie I'm sure yeah basement trolls they
all seriously I don't want to hate on
them because I think those people might
like some of the phones I make one day
and not good I want to get to you down
there in the basement if they can get
reception though yeah I don't know what
type of Internet they're using you know
it's it's yeah great internet and those
computers that but um yeah so the point
is here is like if they're gonna come
and they're gonna say vitriol and stuff
and hate on certain elements of the film
and things that make them feel
uncomfortable my plan is I am going to
use it in advertising I'm gonna use it
in campaigns I there's nothing more I'm
more excited to do than put on a picture
of our main actress walking down the
street in her lap or tan coat a where it
says a a sideshow Liberace of Hollywood
I can't wait to put that on there right
a drum scene it's cool yeah I want to
see the sideshow Liberace Hollywood folk
and to be honest when he said that I was
like
yeah I'm actually good yeah I was
actually watching beyond beyond the
candelabra when I was at a point it's a
really cool trailer by the way and it is
your mother who plays the main character
very cool yeah she's was like directing
my mom awesome she was down she was more
down than I was yeah everyone put her in
your films oh she's down trust me
you can push her to the limit she she
owns a strip club and in the film yeah
she's a she's a strip club owner and
she's had it for you know 30 years and
some guys from the past come to take it
away from her it's kind of a little
killing of a Chinese bookie vibes and
she doesn't go down easy
okay Brian I think everyone covered it
pretty well this is such a depressing
topic and one thing too I don't know if
this sheds any light but if you think
about it too you could you could also
look at the trolls in a way as a
compliment because it might not be
someone in their basement it might be
seeing another filmmaker that didn't get
distribution or that's been out in a
while and it's more like creative
jealousy so you could also look at it in
that light and then know okay maybe not
all right I was trying to bring some
louise hay to it and it didn't work okay
honestly I think fellow filmmakers even
if they're jealous cuz of success they
they know enough about the process of
making a movie I mean look they even
make an awful movie an objectively awful
movie is hard to even make does the
hideous yeah you might hate it two and a
half two I'm not gonna sit there and
berate them for doing so so yeah it
might be awful but you can tell the
filmmaker from not the filmmaker based
on the review
you know that we get kind of sorry just
bringing up what you're saying about the
ratings it's a that's a very limited way
to look at if a film's good or bad is
how many people have clicked on which
star at what time at what point in their
life at any moment you know in it and
it's not necessarily the way that I
would go about or I even do go about
curating my own choices and films I kind
of was thinking of my own behavior
and I was like I've actually never left
a rating on a film even if I hated it or
I loved it so who or who's actually
taking the time to do this still like
log in and like you know and I love but
I just I wouldn't right and so that's
enough on the subject okay so we're
gonna we're gonna shed some we're gonna
have some light come in the room now did
did all of you go to film school and if
you did do you regret it are you happy
that you went and if you didn't go what
are your thoughts yeah I did go to film
school I went to sort of like a more of
a trade school
the documentary program photography it
was a bachelor so it was pretty broad
communication arts
we did make narrative and fiction and
commercial projects while I was there
you know if I were to do my career in
film over again you know I don't think
film school is is necessary you could
basically start as a production
assistant and and really work your way
up and learn the game which is probably
more valuable to you
you know it does help to have a college
degree out there in the world I work for
my you know job I work in the commercial
side of the business I make commercials
produce commercials but pretty much zero
people have ever asked me what school I
graduated from it's all about the real
and the portfolio and my network yeah I
did go to college and I got into the
film department and after two years of
it I was I was actually already working
in the industry doing some art direction
and makeup and different things and so I
kept taking time off of school and I
would go and work on something and I was
doing some editing and so finally after
two years and being faced with classes
on like how many gigawatts it takes to
run a satellite dish and all the stuff
that it's like I don't need to know I
don't want to know
I doubt after two years and then just
kept working and I've never stopped
working since and then my real training
was I did special effects for ten years
so my real training was watching Steven
Spielberg work watching held Ramos work
watching commercial director Jo Pitka
work I mean that's where I learned kind
of what you're saying that that's the
real way to learn it you can certainly
learn the ins and outs and the nuts and
bolts and all and writing classes are
good but I heard some awful statistic
and I think it was about USC that
arguably one of the greatest film
programs in the world that only
something like 1% or 2% of the people
that graduate actually end up working in
the industry some and and I might have
that wrong so don't quote me on it but
it was something incredibly shockingly
low no I never went to film school my
father was a single parent and decided
when I was 3 years old he was in the
move to California become a film
director so he jumped in a car and drove
across the from Florida to California
and he's been doing it ever since so I
grew up going to school going to set
going to school going to say at a
certain point I wanted to get away from
the millet
film industry so I went join the
military I try to get away from this and
I ended up becoming a photographer back
in the business and I did that for three
years for the US Navy and went work for
the government for six years and got
laid off when Obama did his government
contract cutbacks and then I went in
2009 became a PA I was a PA for about 10
or 15 films and the sound called me up
to be a line producer and everything is
for that point though now I've done
close to 70 movies Wow congratulations
it's very cool story similarly my father
was a director as well so I kind of grew
up on set my whole life and I hated it
and then I ended up going to film school
uh-hum so Roger I think the best take
the money from the film school and go
make a movie and that was and my dad
told me that he said dude don't go don't
go but I just wanted to get away from
home I was like I am going and and I
went and I definitely made some
relationships there but you're right
Roger Corman was right take the money go
make a film because what I learned was
there was no there was it wasn't like I
came out of films cause like oh wow I
have this path to success
it was just like as if I hadn't gone I
will say and I had to do the same thing
I do you know steal some money and make
a movie you know the one thing that film
school doesn't teach you what happens if
your actor doesn't show up the next day
what happened if the crew member gets
hurt DP is sick all that stuff is nobody
teaches you that and all the stuff
you're learning in school is your basic
camera stuff lighting it's nothing to do
with the actual people which is where
you take the money go make the movie
you'll learn all of that yeah and I
think the one the one place that I will
give film school credit is allowed me to
to incubate creative thoughts and ideas
with being exposed to new movies and for
me as a filmmaker I'm
I love film I base a lot of what I do
off the movies I love and I'm obsessed
and addicted to watching movies so it
did open me up to some of that but I
would have loved to have taken that film
put it towards a movie had just gone and
made all the mistakes that ended up
making anyway eight years later I did I
will say that hmm a lot of the big
department heads from on my film or
people I graduated college with so I did
get to have some people around me that
were very talented and that I got to you
know be a succubus and use their talent
for my own I mean I know they're very
talented people and talented people help
us make better films so yeah but do the
Roger Corman plan take the money and
make a film Brian anything my dad was an
optical engineer so I unfortunately and
I grew up in the hills of Tennessee
hillbilly
or as we like to call ourselves because
we were sophisticated we were Mountain
Williams so they didn't know what what
the heck to do with me wanting to make
movies this was like my whole family had
no idea but they kind of insisted that I
was gonna go to college it was like you
you were almost ran off and join the
circus because I got to I got to intern
on a horror film with Anthony Perkins
and I almost didn't come back the
wardrobe department kind of sucked me in
and I but I almost didn't come back but
they they got me back and then they said
well you have to go to school and like
well the only thing I care about is
making movies so I guess that's what
I'll do and they're paying for it so I
did it my grandfather paid for it
it was USC it was USC cinema school and
because I guess they had a redneck
quotient they needed to fill out and but
it certainly wasn't the movies I had
made it to that point that got me an I
agree though it's I mean it's a
different error back then this is really
pre-internet definitely like going to
films go back then maybe there was a
reason for it because you could get
exposed to a lot of movies that were
very difficult to see at that time
period
and you could learn from a lot of people
who work in the industry to learn some
craft but that's you don't need to now I
mean you haven't needed to for like ten
years I mean now with the with the
internet you can see every movie there
is out there you can get feedback by
posting your shorts on YouTube and you
can get feedback from people in the
business I'll do it I mean you don't
really need to do it anymore
one plus side of it is I guess I I did
meet like you said I met some some great
people and when we finished we ran off
and did like a 50 minute thesis short on
our own and that was probably that was a
lot of fun and learned a lot from that
and into the process of all that I I met
my wife who I make horror films with so
so that weird chain of events if I
hadn't gone my life would have been very
different in a bad way but yeah I I
don't think it's worth going to film
school taking them up if you have money
to a and you don't wanna get yourself in
debt which is about it anyway
then yes invest it in a feature but
please please please please please do 20
30 shorts before you even think about
doing a feature so you can make a bunch
of mistakes and learn from them so then
you can make a bunch of mistakes when
you make your feature but at least
you're making new mistakes I mean people
who never really made a movie and they
say all I'm gonna do a feature that's is
crazy I was like saying you were gonna
write a novel and you're never in a
paragraph does anybody in the audience
have questions do wanna stop for a
moment and anybody no but Darren yeah
with Darren and then she also sells
things from South Africa to her house
which is amazing and Matt her cat who's
amazing I bought some of her amazing
South African words and don't with
really special so
do you think more people should put her
on she's not gonna introduce herself
this is my guest for the evening this is
Trista Robinson she's the lead actress
in Echo Saphir and she's really great so
any any filmmakers in the house check
out the movie when it comes out and
you'll get to see what she can do but
she's great
what's the website oh the website the
movies echoes of fear food that's when I
mean at the end of the day the Corman
because that's where my father learn
from Roger Corman I'm wearing for my
father you can pay the crew
excuse my language where you can pay the
crew shit you can work long hours all
these things if they're fed well and
they're constantly taken care of
nobody's going to complain yeah we don't
normally do it but that's why your
second meals or one thing in the next
day we always try to make sure the lunch
is better than it was a before because
we might have worked longer I'm a big
Strickler when I'm producing for a 12
hour a day doesn't always happen but you
want to make sure that the food the
craft service you actually pay the
crafty person more than you would
normally member to make sure that the
food is there I found there's certain
things that I've just never been able to
get around like a good 5.1 mix or 7.1
Mayock so those are the things that no
matter how many people you know you can
get favors from color-correction often
to really get good color correction
those are kind of the last steps that
that I've often just had a hard time not
spending money on because I usually
because I can do a lot of it myself but
yes definitely food actors good actors I
mean yeah a lot will work for nothing
for you know for free whatever but
but you need good actors there carrying
your whole movie so you know for me
that's where you got to put some money
and preferably savvy actors and you know
if you can maybe something that happened
while on set or before in pre-production
that film school could not have taught
you for this but since that happened you
were never the same in terms of how you
prepared whether people thought you were
totally OCD but you knew that what you
were doing was right because you never
wanted to have that happen again and you
were probably you were you were
protecting your own production I think
of course it depends on what your goal
is for your film
you know if you're trying to get your
money back
that's a that's one goal if you're
trying to win you know or get into a big
festival that's another goal if you're
just trying to make something that's
another goal for me I think by far the
most eye-opening moment in this business
because I had actually been in the
business for many years working in
commercials I started working
commercials in college and I've I still
do 10 years now and I was always on the
periphery of Hollywood and I I had you
know know people in Hollywood and you
know had a manager and you know talked
to all these different people and I had
made my movie and I had real cast in it
and all this stuff but the one thing I
was not prepared for that I wish I had
done like day one when I got to LA was
go to AFM because that place is the most
eye-opening experience for an
independent filmmaker that you could
have I think in terms of this business
because it's essentially like a giant
bazaar where they take over the whole
Lowe's hotel and every hotel room is an
office of a different sales agent
distributor producer or whatever from
all over the world and they're there and
they're slinging films
and they don't care what your movies
about they want to know who's in it
what's the genre what was the budget I
need and you when you experience that
like firsthand you just you can't I can
tell you this but you can't mentally
understand until you stand in that place
and you walk those floors and you see
how it's done it's it's mind-blowing and
then you realize you're like okay
actually the movie business is kind of
like the forks and knives business like
one fork is made out of titanium and one
is made out of plastic and that's how
they sell these things it's really it's
insane for an artist for a filmmaker you
can't believe that that's how its it's
done so when you left that first time
from from the lows did you feel almost
like shell-shocked a little bit or what
did it give you a new hope because you
realized okay then I can do this in this
and then I felt you know completely
overwhelmed and I don't really get
overwhelmed very easily say cool under
fire but that place it just made you you
feel like wow there's a tidal wave out
there that people are surfing on that
like I didn't even know about or I
wasn't you know I was still like inland
I don't know how to explain it and I
know this sounds naive I know that it's
like oh of course you know FM and film
markets and can and Toronto that's how
they work but again you just don't
really get it until you're standing
there and you're seeing it so that's
great thank you I think I've got two
things one is I think just learning
distribution because you unfortunately
think we probably have all learned the
hard way
and and hopefully you do actually learn
how to do it better that you can
actually make good deals and you don't
have to be so afraid and you don't have
to be so eager or desperate but whether
you make money on your film or whether
your investors make their money back it
lives or dies on the decisions you make
going in to work with the distributor so
I think those are the biggest lessons
that I carry
continue to carry forward and try to
make even to continue to learn and then
my second one is oftentimes we have to
work with named talents and I've just
kind of learned over the years
boy that experience can be good or or
bad and often on our kind of budget
levels we're you know it's not the most
comfortable film it's not what they're
maybe used to it's not the big trailers
and so for me it's important to actually
get to know the people and socialize
with them before I cast them it's not
enough to just meet them in a casting
room I actually like to go out in a
social setting and just see are we gonna
get along or they are they gonna be able
to roll with me on this and go on this
journey with me and not complain about
it and and and the only way to really
that I have found to figure that out is
to to go out with them and socialize a
little bit and and there's always
someone else so if you're getting a bad
vibe from them there's always another
actor because we're not talking about
the A+ level you know talking about some
really great amazing known character
actors and working actors but there will
be somebody else if you don't get a
little if you don't vibe with that
person or you think they're difficult
there there is another person that's
just as qualified and just as good
something that never prepared for and no
one ever told me what happened I can't
actually talk about the movie per se but
I was held for ransom Wow thinking of
that the the crew came first and the
cast and crew came first together when
I'm away from the the area and hoping
that the company I was dealing with
could get me out of there yeah that was
you you asked for a change that's been
my barometer of how bad a movie is it
ain't that bad so I'm doing good I mean
that's that's my day-to-day if
something's really bad it's probably
best that's smart but wow I mean I can't
even imagine I did get permission to do
the making of that film are you making
it
Wow there's so many different people who
were part of it that we're trying to get
everyone's side because what I dealt
with was different than what the other
person dealt with I was just the last
person to leave yeah thank you mom
um I had a moment basically I think the
biggest thing I took from like one of my
learning experience was if you don't do
it when you're on set and when you're
shooting you're never gonna get a chance
to do it so I held a post doesn't exist
yeah exactly so like if your gut if
you're like like I had a there's a one
shot in my film queen that I don't have
a moment and every time I watch it I am
upset that I just I let it all get away
from me to not get this one thing that I
really wanted because if I if I don't do
it then I'm never gonna get to do it
afterwards there's no budget there's no
real thing called reshoots
you know there's picking up maybe little
pieces here and there and but yeah
there's no fixing an impost
so yeah so it's like trust it like that
moment was I didn't trust my gut well I
did I knew what my got one and I went
with kind of the sway of everyone else
wanting to do something else and I was
talked out of something and I wish I
wasn't
and I still love I mean his just that
one moment and I realized I will never
let that happen again
those on those you know twelve hours of
those days that we're on set and we're
shooting in this tight time you know
that's your time as a filmmaker and it's
everyone else's but it's yours because
you live with it forever and I said to
actually the person that was evolved
that kind of forced it to not happen I
said you know what you walk out of here
and for the phone was 12 days so you
walk away in 12 days and you never have
to worry about this again I live with
this for the rest of my life and it
sounds severe but it feels severe when
you do we all know these films define us
for the rest of our lives I'll just
follow that thread because I really like
what you're saying I would say in
in the indie world especially and really
you should be any world but they'll
never do it on the on the bigger movies
because they can just spend money later
but it it on the indie world especially
it's like and I say this even at the
jobs I work it's like they're really the
motto needs to be fixed it and pre you
have to fix it in pre-production there's
always going to be surprises in
production but you need to like map it
out so there were surprises it's not
stuffy shouldn't have already like
figured out ahead of time I mean when we
learned a great discipline which I'm
glad we learned this discipline my wife
and I cuz when we first started doing
the movies we were shooting in sixty
millimeter he's you know the CP sixteen
vietnam war camera and when you're
shooting an ultra low-budget indie film
and sixty millimeter and you're paying
for that film stock and that processing
and that transfer you know what you're
shooting and you figure it out ahead of
time because you don't have the film to
burn through multiple takes or coverage
I mean I had I had boards and it
basically like if there was a close-up
in the board that's because I knew that
line was the close-up I couldn't run
that scene for is a no-no that's the
line I'm in the close-up here I'm in the
two-shot because it's like you can't so
that we've tried to carry that
discipline over to the digital age and I
think it's really a good discipline to
have you can always be spontaneous and
come up with new ideas on the set and
and seize the moment but it's always
good to like have that thing to fall
back on it's basically having it prepped
out so I would say that's that will
really help you and anything you do is
basically prep it out as much as
possible and even though it makes you a
little bit paranoid and crazy
you basically have to play the game if
you're producing it yourself of thinking
of every possible scenario that can go
wrong and you'll still be surprised but
you it kind of makes you a little bit
crazy because you're like oh I'm gonna
go here and we're gonna shoot well it's
like well is it trash day when you shoot
when it's trash day on that street you
know things like that you have to always
think of like anything that could
possibly go wrong which is a miserable
thing to do but you have to so then why
do it
if it's so stressed half - because there
was any way you could do anything else
you would stop but you can
is there a point where you say this is
my last one oh and then and then you let
a day go by and you say well okay maybe
maybe I'll you know think about it and
then two days later you're ready to do
another one okay I could do anything
else I've heard that from mother
filmmaker guy one person said I could be
a busboy or I could be a filmmaker that
works with the government it was in the
military and they didn't do very well so
so no filmmaking I think there's no
other option anyone well I mean we you
know yeah
me personally I am kind of at a point
where it starts to feel like a very
expensive hobby and it just can't be you
know I mean maybe you can be for some
people you know if that's okay but I
think it's for me it's always just
trying to figure how to do the business
better and and but no this is all I mean
literally 33 years this year in the
business and I've never worked in any
other industry or held any other kind of
job what's the question why do this to
yourself yeah I think you know for any
of us it's it's all comes back to the
desire to tell stories and you know
create interesting or unique or
compelling visuals and sound and put
them into a montage and you know how
people experience that I think that
that's that's it that's really all there
is one of my mentors he's actually his
name is Charlie midnight he's a
songwriter he's a Grammy winning
songwriter and he I get to sit in on a
lot of his like kind of sessions he has
with musicians and you know he basically
every one of them he just starts with
like you have to do this because you
love the process of it and there's gonna
be a million obstacles and you just you
have to be into the process
because if you think you're gonna like
you're only gonna be happy if you're you
know Lady gaga
like that you know it has to be about
the process I think that I mean I do it
I mean along the lines is like its
addicting it's it's like I mean it's
like the drugs I get the that first day
on set is the most like spine-tingling
numb stomach curling and feeling I've
ever had
and then the twelve hours end and you
feel like you've done everything wrong
he's probably go jump off a cliff and
the next day begins and then you get in
the rhythm and it's like you're making
this you know you just fill this you're
creating this monster or a baby or
creation or whatever each time and for
me like it's a little I guess
masochistic my love of making movies
because it's definitely and it comes at
a price and I think everyone pays their
own price whether you know I think
there's people who make 100 million
dollar movies that pay a certain price
for making those but it's addicting
that's why I do it and like ever so what
else am I gonna do like I'm not very
good with a hammer you know I'm good at
like hammering a prosthetic you know I
just I mean I get what you're saying
about masochism but I think you know
masochism pain is this intense pleasure
magnified for the effect so if you just
look at it that way but just because
this thing will probably be online and
my dad hates it when I say it it will be
yeah III got my first memory when I was
3 years old was pulling about the
blankets in my bed and a skeleton being
there and running down the steps my
second memory is my mom chewing out my
dad so I think it's like I've always
been drawn to this weird McCobb and
darkness and I think it's like what you
were saying about storytelling it's
really like you have to tell the stories
and for whatever reason if you're making
movies it's because you need to tell
that's the meat
chosen you to tell the story I mean if
you could just write novels there be a
painter or whatever but I think all of
us up here obviously this is the medium
which is it's almost chooses you it's
like this is the only you can try to
outlet that storytelling and creativity
in other ways and I've tried but in the
end it's just doesn't work the only way
it works is if it's visual the visual
medium and I have no idea why that is
I'm hoping we can take a break for
everybody in a second we just had one
question in the back West which is that
business is changing and and do you feel
without being stubborn and trying to be
objective do you feel like it's it's
headed to a place where you guys have to
change the medium of storytelling right
and you know you guys are making films
for an audience will will the audience
be depleted so much where it just
doesn't make financial sense for you
guys to make a movie and because I'm
sort of thinking about whether making
features is the is the ultimate you know
for me and whether I can explore you
know whether it's a bunch of short films
or web all you guys and you know are you
guys thinking about that how does the
business side of it you know the horizon
affected you're thinking about making
the are
to do this you know because I had
totally get that it's a great question
thank us I'll start down the line again
I'm you know newcomer to it my film was
released you know this summer in America
and around the world and my experience
just in the three years process it took
to make dramatically changed so when I
started in 2015 at that point Netflix
and Amazon were literally buying like
every film at Sundance right fast
forward to last year and they bought
zero films at Sundance they're the two
biggest disruptors in the game they have
all the studios like you know bending in
half so but they changed literally
they're buying model within the period
of time that I was making my film now
I'm not saying I was like expecting
Netflix to come and buy my movie or
whatever but it was certainly in the
game plan you know in the beginning like
that's an option right so I think that
the business is changing so quickly it's
a little hard to Bank on you know and
that's the main issue I would say
certainly with features are certainly
with an independent film that takes X
amount of time that you don't have a you
know delivery deadline on and you don't
have the resources to meet that deadline
specifically you know obviously episodic
is undergoing a massive renaissance but
they're also over 500 scripted
television shows you know amongst the
various channels so it's very crowded so
that I mean I think your question is
basically like the pinnacle question for
any independent artists at this moment
is what is the you know structure of
film and where is the potential to have
fiscal return because I know that's part
of your your question and the answer is
that nobody knows so that's that's the
answer as far as I know and I'm sure
these guys have a lot more to go on yeah
I mean if you you know if you look back
15 years ago if someone said to you back
then YouTube and Netflix and Amazon are
going to rule television you you
would've thought that's nuts
that's insane that'll never happen and
it's happened so I think it's impossible
to predict you just have to be smart
about it and I'll go back to
distribution the traditional
distribution models and and deals just
do not work in this environment anymore
and so you can't be afraid to say they
were distributors no that doesn't work
because I know I will never see a penny
of this and it doesn't work for me and
that's where you say thank you and they
say thank you and you go on to the next
one and you can't be afraid to do that
all you can do is try you can just try
to try to be smart try to see what the
trends are try to see how other people
are doing it but I think it's impossible
to to be that forward-thinking and and
know what's going to happen or what the
technology is going to be so um that's a
fine line between doing this for the art
and feeding our artistic Souls and doing
it as a business and and just finding
that perfect marriage I do a thing
called production service which is so to
first answer the first part of the
question you can't predict what's
happening on what's going to happen so
to build a do one or two films of mine a
year and I do the business side of it
which is I do a production service where
I work for other companies I bring my
team they give me a script in the budget
I go make their film for them so I still
get to create and make a film for a
product but I'm getting paid to do the
nd stuff throughout the year we pick one
or two projects that we fund or we find
funding ourselves and we make those
films knowing that we we either have a
distribution in place
or we know a person who will shop it for
us and those people are usually
up-to-date with what's happening
otherwise really just avoid making if
you if you're putting a lot of money
into something we avoid making something
we don't know what will happen so we try
to pick a topic or a genre that will to
this day still sell it's quite hard
horror never dies in that aspect so it's
it's a good that's a good xian'er to
stick with if you're trying to basically
make something that you can sell
everything else at that point action
does well other projects you're really
just kind of gambling or taking a chance
on yourself and losing that money to
create so yeah I mean I think along
those lines is we've seen my first films
got released but I've worked in that
phone was room for ten years until then
doing all sort of a job and every
position possible and I produce as well
um and I think what we found is you know
not long ago the model was that you can
put someone's face on a decent
well-known actors face on a film and you
get money to do it from overseas and
then you know you could Bank it off that
and that was that and a lot of bad
movies got made off that and some really
good ones I think now we're in the state
like everyone's saying where no one
really knows what's going on I think the
two answers that I'm trying to stick to
and I know they're still tightly
abstract but one is keep your costs low
you know you don't need that much money
to make a good film especially if it's a
personal one especially if it's one
that's not necessarily cast based or
targeted at certain you know audiences
and the other thing is you know I really
do believe this that like even though
it's hard good films find a way and good
cinema finds its way through the masses
and navigates to the masses and has a
lifespan that you that it can make money
off but no there's so many different
ways to diversify now in film I mean
some of the great filmmakers are just
looking at new forms of technology right
now that every worried about
in normal narrative features you know
they're looking at VR and they're
looking at AR and they're looking at I
saw I saw a guy knows a very good
television writer did a snapchat show
and I don't you snapchat I can't even I
don't even like that stuff but it was
phenomenal I was blown away by how good
it was you know so there's a whole world
of I think diversifying our content I
think the idea of like of like branded
short feature is going away
and we're entering a new world where
it's gonna be a very audience based and
I think one other thing that's going on
is is being able and I haven't gone
through it yet but I am definitely have
a project that I'm looking at this is
his self distribution
I think there's becoming more and more
avenues we all have the same outlets
most these distributors all they're
gonna do is put some paid ads on
Facebook paid ads on Instagram cut a
trailer that you could probably cut
better than them half the time and you
know and make a poster for your film
like you could do a lot of this stuff
you know maybe but they're starting to
be a lot of programs that allow
filmmakers to have access to the
platforms that once we were blocked from
so I think you have to embrace it I'm a
traditional guy I go to the movies I
watch films and the theater I'm not a
big tech person I'm not a big streaming
person you know I love that I love the
movie theater but we can go straight to
the consumer now and that empowers us as
much as it also hinders us you know it's
a it's a ying and yang a double-edged
sword on that one but I think there's a
lot to be taken from that and I think
self distribution is gonna have its
place very shortly in the industry just
following that thread I mean the self
distribution model if you want to do it
is already here there's basically they
call them aggregators but there's
companies out there I guess I shouldn't
name companies but there are companies
out there that that basically will take
your film and they don't even take a
percentage of it you're basically paying
them and they will basically pitch it
and place it to the different platforms
and they'll put them out there and
they'll just be out there and then it's
totally up to you to spin I don't know
ten to thirty thousand dollars in your
marketing and everything else you're
gonna do so you people are aware the
movie is even out there and then so you
can do that I would say for going to
traditional distributors which is what
we're looking for right now is you
basically have to find one that's
actually going to put some muscle behind
it because there's a lot of distributors
out there oh take the movie and they'll
just do the same thing they'll just dump
it out there but they're taking their
percentage of your movie but they're not
gonna do anything to promote it or
market it or anything like that that's
probably the worst thing you can do
because now you're losing like 25
percent of the revenue and it's just
sitting out there and unless you pay
yourself to market it what you have to
do as well no one even knows it's there
so that's kind of happening and changing
right now but there are still
distributors hopefully talking to some
that will actually do a little bit to
push the movie that might make them
worth you know going that route the
other thing is I think what you said
it's just keep your costs low which is
all part of like learning do the shorts
learn how to make movies learn every
aspect of the movie my wife and I we do
so many of the different roles ourselves
because we've been doing it for so long
it's not like we're just trying to do
things we've never done before but like
doing the basic audio work we go to some
place to get out of Sweden but doing the
basic audio work and laying down the
audio tracks the cinematography when I
watch the shooter she shoots on other
shows I'm probably telling TV shows and
stuff and so if you can the more hats
you can wear yourself and do the work
you can lower the costs and and that
helps a lot in regards to like you know
everything's changing now in terms of
like there's different ways like you
said to tell stories once again I just
tell features because for whatever
reason this is the outlet for me like a
90 minute or less kind of feature thing
this is my ideas lend themselves and
want to be in that kind of format like
tell a story beginning middle and end
that's complicated enough so you need
that running time so that that's it's
why I do it if I was drawn towards
there's not really money in it but if I
was drawn to her like telling little
five-minute stories and that's what's my
passion I'd probably just be doing that
it's not like I said I don't know how
you make any money from that but that
wouldn't be the issue that would be my
passion that's what I would do but
because it's like narrative feature
filmmaking then it's kind of like it's
the reverse of a normal business you
don't your normal business says oh I'm
gonna figure out what the market is and
did it today
no it's like it's it's kind of reversed
it's like I really need to do this I
can't not do this so how can I make that
viable which business-wise is not very
smart but once again I'm it's not coming
at it from that way but definitely
keeping costs low looking at the
different options there's a lot of
different options now that's the plus
side is there's a lot of different
options the downside was in the past if
you could get a distributor you'd be
like yeah I got a distributor and that
would mean something because there
weren't that many and the ones that did
it could do it we like this how far back
we go we actually went to the can full
market ourselves at one point with two
of our movies because we got the rights
back and someone screwed us over and so
did territory and didn't tell us so we
got the rights back so we actually had
two movies in a booth at the can foe
market selling movies directly to buyers
and we did it and we made money and
we're like wow we could do this but the
flip side of that is that's all you'll
be doing because you really need to be
there for like five to ten years and pay
you have to be taking other filmmakers
and then pretty soon you're just a
distributor yeah I mean that's the whole
thing with the foreign sellers agent and
a good distributor is a good one
which will pay you they have their
relationships they've developed the
relationships over 10 to 20 years and
it's those relationships which enables
them to make the sales the same way that
the the film reps and stuff can get a
film place in a festival it's the
relationships with the film directors at
those a festival directors that though
at those festivals so it's really a
relationship game and that's the
advantage of getting a distributor if
they're a good one if they're buy
distributor then you obviously they're
not worth it well why don't we turn it
over to the audience does anybody have
okay oh wow okay this gentleman here
first
thanks for
great listen to your journeys you talked
about creative process
distribution some other stories but the
questioning effort all of you
financing your first experiences with
financing and how you finance your first
projects and where you are currently
with financing your your dreams where
you are never change sure with with my
film mad genius I did some pretty
creative financing in the beginning I
essentially financed a key part which
was my casting director and I knew that
I was gonna make this film of my own
accord and I was out there like super
Wild West style I had no distributor I
had no sales agent I had no real
producer I just know I was gonna make
this movie so I was willing to to do
crazy things and so the first thing I
did was invest in my casting director
and we started doing auditions of the
script and the people that she brought
in because she was so terrific like blew
my mind I couldn't believe the actors we
were getting to audition and to tape and
to meet with me because I was literally
offering sag ultra low budget you know
minimum so once we had you know some
really great cast in and cast I should
put a caveat in that like he was saying
earlier the old method of financing your
film off huge cast with foreign sales is
that's still out there it's not as big
as it used to be but you have to have
big actors to do that we're talking like
top 100 you know kind of actors my
actors were just really amazing and had
been in real films you know like Iron
Man at Star Trek and you know TV shows
and they were willing to do my crazy
little movie so that was that's what
really kicked it off and then that's
what allowed me to go then raise private
money you know just enough basically and
I wanted to keep the budget really low
because I knew as a real gamble that if
we would make it back so you your
funding was all based on your cast
yeah and me as a commercial director I
had a real visual effects experience
you know I was a real package for my
tiny movie right plus these actors plus
the genre and the scale of it and so
people said why the hell not you know
kind of thing and then you know moving
forward I definitely you know personally
will never sell finance you know
speculation project again but that's
just a personal thing so I'm looking at
more you know traditional and through
Hollywood routes you know for my next
projects a little yeah of course paper
is always better for money people write
like a letter of intent and although
that's hard to do because usually
there's that cold catch-22 of you can't
go out to name actors unless you've got
your funding in place but they help you
get your funding in place and it's
that's always a really tricky thing to
navigate might have been just a
combination of things nothing terribly
interesting from me self financing to
private equity I've been looking into a
little more doing foreign pre-sales but
doesn't excite me that much because
you're giving away a lot for very little
yeah just a little bit of everything
it all starts the same way it was self
financing the very first one and then
over time I'd be able to get together
with different investors and as by
depending on the project that can take
certain projects to these the best
but the very first one was so financed
you man you go into private investors
you're making enough money to you know
keep your investors happy so you can
keep doing this
I haven't throw to a degree but again
it's it's knowing the project that will
sell a lot of times when I want to make
a film myself I still have to raise my
own money because it's I don't know if
it's gonna sell but I want to make it
where if I have a project I know will
sell then I go to our investors mine was
my queen queen of Halle Boulevard was
interesting we kind of three three steps
of financing one was we my grandma died
which gave me just enough to like pay
for some of the crew and then my one of
my producers family was very generous
and then a production company company
that I work with on a lot of other
projects while commercial company helped
bankroll part of the film on a credit
card and just trusted me that I would
out of our good faith in working
relationship that I would get it back to
them and I was on like good I got to
meet all these like benchmarks with them
and then we only had enough to get
through production um knowing that I
could do as much as opposed as I could
myself we raised $22,000 off Kickstarter
in the end I it was you know Kickstarter
we got it was a gamble we wouldn't have
been able to finish the film honestly
without it because we had no a lot of
that money went back to paying back the
production company that it loaned me the
money and all of this and a lot of my
own like credit cards and all this were
in it as well and those are still not
back but so yeah it was kind of like a
mixture of things again the Kickstarter
at the end was really helpful
I would suggest anyone doing a
Kickstarter that I think that is the
proper order of ways to to make the film
as much as you can yourself show that
you got something that you got skin in
the game and really people fall
people got in line and liked it random
people I had never met before came
through with very big donations to the
film and investments in it
yeah and that was that for my second
movie it was honestly it was kind of a
dream situation I walked into a already
financed movie that budget was many
times larger than my first one and no it
was a time movie but it was different
and it was more for hire but it was I
loved the film it's a it's I loved it so
yeah so I've kind of had an interesting
way of raised money now I'm raising
money for another movie and it's kind of
like going back to the drawing board
again and seeing you know with these
showing that I've made these movies
before who is willing to you know going
to people that I know are either in it
for they want to support cool
interesting movies they have the funds
to do so which there's not a ton of
people who do that but if there are you
go to them and then traditional just you
know financing distribution models to
try to get the starter cash to get the
films going and to get this more thing
like he said was like getting the
casting director because that really
kick starts the film into gear and casts
everything on these films even that
giant cast like a real cast makes it a
real movie and that just starts gets the
ball rolling so I think that's actually
a great piece of advice is getting like
the cat pay your casting director to get
him on fast and the movie will start
rolling yeah well first film I think
this is a comments write your first film
was we came up with this crazy idea
because I wanted to do a feature my
wife's like well just do one so
basically we she came about this crazy
idea that we would get him people
involved in the movie and part of their
involvement in the movie is they put
money in it and everyone would have a
piece of it and we just did the movie so
we were putting in our money a little
bit and then we went to someone we knew
who was a friend who was interested in
film and wanted to get involved in that
and he said well how much more do you
need and we told him he goes okay I'll
put in the rest and that was the end of
that journey so that that was a very
micro budget Micro Micro
budget at low budget horror film even
though we were shooting film and you
know his first films he gets screwed
over every which way by distributors and
we still because the budget was low
enough everyone got the money back so
fairly successful for a first film three
films in between today the last film
that we did I basically did the little
song-and-dance where I wrote a script
for someone and they said you know write
it for this budget so I wrote it for
that budget and they said oh my god the
script it would cost this much money
which is exactly the but to kill me
right for it so I went back and rewrote
it for the new budget and then ain't got
all greenlit and everything which I'm
aware enough to know that means nothing
and then sure enough it just disappeared
didn't happen why that well the time
suck of like two years of my life and so
I'm like I gotta make another movie now
because I have this window where like I
start to go insane if I haven't done a
movie and now it was hitting that
insanity window and so I basically to
buckle down and this idea that we talked
about a long time and my wife and I
basically said okay let's just go back
to where we did the first one we got a
lot of equipment now I've done a lot of
films we know a lot of people we can do
a lot of in-kind a lot of deferments and
we just need to really raise the money
to be able to pay the crew and the actor
isn't that kind of the key two key
things course food but my wife's French
and she's a great cook so she actually
did catering and everyone was very happy
about that actually because it was
really good lunches Tristan will vouch
for that absolutely so so basically we
we just decided to do it that way and
just you know take the time it was going
to take because we knew it was gonna
take longer to do it that way because we
were basically both working jobs in the
industry to get the money we needed so
we kind of had a little bit of start and
stopping because of that but the movie
turned out great we're really really
happy with it so there's a lot of
different ways to do it obviously the
best way is if you can get private
investors or get involved with a
production company or some one of the
finances it which makes it more of a
work for hire but if it's the right
person who believes it understands the
script it isn't going to mess it up
that's a great scenario too so I think
where there's a will there's a way if
you're willing to put any effort into it
Kickstarter front course with my project
that was an option right and a friend of
mine is a mentor she really discouraged
me from doing a Kickstarter because if
it fails it stays there on Kickstarter
forever until they take it down and at
the time that seemed like a really dire
thing to me
but since then you know three years
later and after having done the thing
what I've come to realize is that
Kickstarter is an incredible way to test
the market with your project if you
don't get funded well then you kind of
realize well shit no one wants to see
this right if you do and you blow the
doors off it's like wow okay people
really want to see this project and that
can save you right three years or
whatever if your projects not right for
the market luckily - turned out to be
right for the market but I realized that
in hindsight you know that's should
probably be the entire years to figure
out step one go to a FM walk around get
your mind blown
step two talk to as many people as you
can about that question at a FM step
three read everything you can online
for me it's all about the waterfall
learn the waterfall it's where people in
the process take their money and and
that makes such a big difference the
question you asked could take us forever
to answer there is honesty man there's
no right answer there's no right answer
is no wrong answer you have to just go
out and listen and watch and read and
meet and I hate going to events and I go
because I need to understand what's
happening with our business and again
what you're asking is they also just
deals with how our business is changing
right now yeah so I can answer a
question to you that I know it's
happening right the second but tomorrow
will be different
I've only had to do one distribution
deal in my life but I've been privy to
several others of films I produced like
he said you talk about it all day
first want to keep their marketing costs
low just as a rule of thumb just look at
the marketing costs one of the jobs I'm
a filmmaker and I decided because I got
screwed my first projects in
distribution I decided to take a job
just to learn the inside and in six
months I learned as an indie the thing
that you need to look out for is the
marketing cost cap them put the cap in
the contract whether it's 15 or 35 but
cap it or you will never see it I mean
yeah like you said like that is every
cost inside the contract should have a
cap its DVD costs if it's the PR cost if
it's there recoupment everything should
be capped off and you need to get out
everything else all the expenses have to
be directly reported none of this like
blanket expense thing like all 50000
expenses what does that mean it's they
got it's got to be like transparent in
terms of what they're spending I mean a
great if it's just if this was like 10
years ago I could tell you some great
people to go to but they
do it anymore or they've moved up to
only doing like five million dollar
movies but we had a foreign sales agent
it was fantastic they would actually
give you the contract the actual
contract that they signed with the other
country they made the deal - that's how
transparent they were it was amazing and
they always paid never better to shake
them down but that's all like you just
gotta ask a bunch of other filmmakers
who they've gone with what their
experience is because that's not even
gonna be reflected in the contract you
can have terms in the contract it
doesn't mean they'll do the terms and
then where are you arbitration hiring a
lawyer so the only other thing besides
marketing I guess one tidbit of advice
is make sure there are benchmarks on the
movie you know if you can't get it in
advance which is always the best
then get a minimum guaranteed what's the
second best if you can't get it even if
you get those things you just basically
have to have automatic return of your
rights if certain things aren't met so
you don't to go to a lawyer
like if they want to take the film for
seven years well an X number of years
and you can negotiate what this amount
is you need to see X amount in your
pocket or the rights automatically
revert back to you you know they get a
lawyer you do anything if you don't
receive X amount of money and the same
thing you want it for three years by the
third year you have to have X amount of
money
or the rights automatically revert to
back to you so it's done you don't feel
worried about hiring a lawyer and
contact it meets in the contract it's
now once your movies out and distributed
you're kind of toast because it's not a
new movie anymore but at least you're
not going to be spending additional
money to try to get the rights to your
movie back so that's something yeah I
think that the bottom line is if you
don't fully trust your distributor
you're better off self distributing in
this moment in time because I imagine
your movie is not probably starring a
major actor and not you know having like
major backing other questions there is
something about
my situation people and and I came up
against my wall were you know like I can
sit on it and wait for a situation by
then the movies my feeling is if you
wait too long I know a lot of filmmakers
who fall in love the idea of the film in
their head and for me I'd rather have a
movie that's done and that's rated B and
a movie that's perfect that's a that's
either in my head or if no one ever sees
so I think that you guys you gotta find
the balance and it's about the volume
that you work as opposed to getting that
one yeah you know that was the guy I had
a crazy notion after the process for my
film it wouldn't have worked for my film
but we're discussing keeping your costs
low and your first one and all that
stuff if you if it were my first one
right now if I was starting right today
doing my first feature and I was again
willing to just make it and just
whatever it took me to do to make it I
would consider looking at putting it on
YouTube and figure out how many views do
I have to get for advertising dollars to
pay for my super tiny budget and then
how much would it take you know to
promote it to got to that place and you
could potentially because now you're
defeating piracy now you're defeating
the whole game of distribution if you go
in from the beginning saying you know
what this film is gonna only cost me ten
grand to make and if I get whatever 2
million views then I've just made money
on it on YouTube and I don't know those
numbers specifically I just completely
made those up but figure it out
and maybe you could do that for your
first one
right to make something it's an idea
yeah I think I think it's a valid idea
by will safety if you want to go that
route you might also want to look into
the aggregator situation where they
don't take the rights to your movie
you're paying a certain amount for it to
be pitched but that way you can not like
you can basically get it across a bunch
of platforms and then now the revenue
that comes in goes to you they don't
even have a piece of it because you've
already done they don't take the thing
of the aggregators is they don't take
the rights to your movie you're paying
basically ala carte it's like this
amount of money and it's gonna be
pitched to all these different networks
and channels and VOD + s do t if your
movies any good you're gonna get on to a
lot of them and then all the revenue
that generates from that will come will
come to you
so it's something else to look at in
addition to the it's a way basically by
its it's self distribution but it's a
little bit of a help because those
aggregators have that once again it's
relationships they have the relationship
so they can go to all those people and
pick the movie and stuff of that kind of
so it's something it's something to look
into
in addition to like that you tomorrow if
you want to avoid traditional
distribution so you all had said earlier
oh sorry Robert go ahead ok we'll come
back to you ok yeah Robert please you
have a floor
my film was a SAG altra low-budget which
is 250 thousand or less arranged my
first one was modified low but we shot
that in 35 and so that was a little
pricier film second one ultra ultra low
same with the third one ultra low but I
talked a lot to distributors now and
there is kind of a model a lot of them
have a model of keep it under five
hundred thousand keep it at four hundred
thousand so I'm starting to hear that a
little bit more that that kind of works
for them to make it back but I've done
everything from five grand upwards of
five to ten million it's just really
depends of the project my personal stuff
is usually for a quarter I'm in the
no-man's land of the microphone yeah I'm
just you know I know Maya my first film
was a little over a hundred and my
second if I talk about budgets
my wife will fly in from the Philippines
from her shoot and kill me I'll do our
first one
alright so our first what we did we see
here by the time we finished and it was
all said and done I think we spent
$20,000 but we shot in 16 millimeter I
think when you take away from stock
processing and transfer and everything
else I think we were left with about six
thousand dollars actually do the movie
other movies are a lot more than that
but the other flip of it is when you
give a budget it's like there's the cash
budget and there's the real budget I
think a lot of us up here probably put
in a lot of like non-cash budget like
in-kind which is part of your budget I
mean your time your energy your in-kind
services what you're not paying yourself
that's truly part of the budget this is
maybe not the cash
but it's part of the budget so when
people say oh I did the movie for
$10,000
not really well they're saying is they
spent $10,000 in cash it's nots not
really the true budget of what they did
in the movie because they're not
factoring in their time all their
friends times who put in time that's all
value so I don't think there's anything
to be gained anymore - by saying how
little you spend I I I don't think it
helps you anymore it helps you to know
how much you spent that you kept your
costs low so your so that means it's
easier to give your money back but in
terms of advertising it I don't know
used to be like a badge of honor like
Rodriguez would say hello Lee spent
which is also not true that's not what
he spent and what's against the cash
budget he spent a lot more than that and
then Miramax picked up the movie and
spent two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars more and that's the movie
everybody saw was a $250,000 movie no
one saw Rodriguez is $10,000 el Mariachi
because it was never distributed
that's just what he did to make people
putting all this money before they saw
in the theater but it was still called a
ten thousand dollar movie because back
then there was some marketing cachet to
that but I don't think this is a happy
question this is a good one so yeah I
know we're trying we're trying to keep
the happy happiness barometer up here
what is your proudest moment as a
filmmaker what what whether it's just
somebody wrote you an email that was
kind that said your film really touched
me or you know going to a festival where
you got a standing ovation there just
what was your proudest moment yeah my
proudest moment I would say has really
just been the overall process and
experience I've had you know a lot of
really amazing feedback some amazing
reviews I'm really great friends with my
cast and crew you know like we're really
family I could call any of them at any
time you know we've made money really
just the whole thing has been a
wonderful experience there hasn't been
anyone
massive you know moments or anything but
the the whole experience proudest moment
yeah maybe on my second movie which we
made back in 2012 it was one of those
magical things we made I made it in
Jefferson City Missouri at an old
abandoned not abandoned a prison a very
very old prison and none of the actors
that the LA actors that I flew out there
nobody knew each other I didn't need the
crew we mean it was all we were all new
to each other but still to this day what
five five years later whatever we're
really good friends and since that same
kind of family thing I mean really good
friends the actors of all state friends
I've stayed I mean genuine friends not
just you know location friends for a
year and even with the people of the
city and and the mayor and you know I
mean it's just like it's just like we're
all really close and it was a very
unique experience because not every
movies like that you're all there's a
little love affair for like a year and
then you all move on and start your
affair with your next crew you know so
yeah so that and also just a little
personal thing on Kings of the evening
my composer Kevin Tony he got an email
from Paul Williams very famous composer
head of ASCAP who just said very nice
things about the score in the movie and
that was just one thing for me my little
geeky thing because he you know Paul
Williams did all the music for for the
Muppet movie and and you know it's very
famous songs and so that was a little
personal just triumph for me probably
last year I did a I have some friends of
mine who were finishing up a show called
the bay and on Amazon and they had
troubles towards the end of their third
season and I stepped in to kind of help
them finish it well in return they gave
me a producing credit and by chance they
ended up winning an Emmy
so with that and then my 14 year old
daughter was my date so for me that was
that's a cool story mine was when my
film world premiered in Boston at I went
to college in Boston at the first
theater that I went to in Boston to see
a movie when I went to college with my
mom on stage with me and yeah it was
pretty wild and she's had kind of a
interesting journey so it was nice
seeing her up there in front of everyone
it's cool too yeah I would say it it is
this last film echoes a fear that we
just started showing a week and a half
just finished and just start showing a
week and a half ago at festivals and I
say that because this is the fifth film
by my wife and I which feels like just
an incredible with all the experiences
over the years accomplishment to get to
that our fifth work phone together but
this is also the first one we've always
been kind of we've always been a team
but this is the first one she's
officially co-director on and it's also
the best movie we've ever made and I
don't think that's a coincidence so it
to me it's like a really proud moment
that we totally have just fused it to
the point where it's like our mu be
absolutely hundred-percent completely
and then to get the best response we
have ever had before
for a movie from that with with the
three festival showing the three awards
but more than the awards is the audience
reaction from a hardcore horror audience
to see them respond so excited to the
movie is such a validation in terms of
what we've done kits like I said we've
worked on it so hard and so long you
can't see the forest for the trees you
know what your intentions were but what
matters is how people react and respond
to it so to see that response from the
exact audience that we're trying to
reach I think to me was it's been the
most rewarding thing and having that
happen with my wife it's been great
thank you
does anybody else have other questions I
don't want to drain us we'll have
nothing left
all right just one last funny because I
also met my wife proud it's more like
more you know the best thing maybe call
it proud but yeah cast her as the lead
in my first movie and that was 11 years
ago now and we have the most amazing
little four-year-old almost five years
old that's good
well my casting director actually takes
credit for our child okay why do they
get a percentage my SADS send her to
college
okay last just what movie do you wish
you had made and it pained you to this
day that you didn't make it and it's not
yours it's someone else's this is
supposed to be an easy fun light
question whether it's Apocalypse Now you
know whatever it is just for you just
you just say one title and that's it
move on pass the mic right Yeah right
where it just pains you you you you know
the better you know the movie almost as
good as as well as the filmmaker does
inside and out I wouldn't say I know the
film as well as the filmmaker but Fight
Club the sappy side of me really loves
Love Actually I just find it to be a
perfect movie and but also about Schmidt
oh and love that film yeah I'm not
saying I should ever make anyone else's
film but I will say I would never make
as good a film but a taxi driver I
honestly don't know how to respond to
this question because because all the
movies I really really love I think they
were done by exactly the right person
who did them so I can't I don't think I
can really answer that what if you could
go in a time machine and become that
person who but but is there movie I mean
it's if you could morph it I can't even
think
fair enough all right well thank you
guys we you know this is fantastic we
were hoping to do a panel and and film
it and it has been wonderful to have all
of you here and this was our second one
so thank you for making this special
because this is all new and we have our
own growing pains with it so this was
very cool thank you very much thank you
thank you to the audience thinking